how would you advise someone to go
through breaking up with a partner then
normally you'll know but what is also
true is sometimes you don't know
sometimes you're sort of allergic to
your relationship and you're so scared
of the other side because you're so
terrible at being alone that you've got
this thing of like even if this is it's
better than nothing and that's never
True by the way like being single isn't
the easiest thing in the entire world
but it's objectively better than going
to bed besides someone who you hope
stops breathing in the middle of the
nights like just that disappointment
every morning when your alarm clock goes
off you gotta remember if you're in a
relationship or you don't like the other
person you owe it to them not to waste
their time anymore if you're not allowed
to text them what's the optimal way to
try and get it done you don't want to
hurt them you don't want to hurt
yourself it's the perfect cocktail to
not make a decision the brutal truth of
it is you are not responsible for other
people's feelings and emotions or their
actions it's not a matter of not being
empathetic it's a nice thing to feel
that concern for other people that's
empathy don't lose that